how long do you think it's too long for
a girl to stay in the talking phase
oh what is the talking phase define like
like you're
um oh gosh because you can use it in so
many terms let's say sleeping with a guy
so she's sleeping with it yeah
and then what's coming out of that phase
like when you say like who wants a
relationship
it's like how dating until it's too long
oh yeah pretty much
how long's a piece of string i would
honestly i would say
anything longer than four months is way
too long
if you're look if you're looking for a
relationship yeah
i'd say within four within three four
months a guy knows if he wants to be in
a relationship with you and if you don't
make him make a decision
he won't make a decision
um because if a guy can sleep with you
and other girls at the same time he's
going to do that i would have said three
months too so it's interesting we're at
the same time why did you come to three
months
um
i don't know it's just like what i've
seen
yeah like
um
i don't know i feel like if three months
you know a person yeah before that like
you could just be getting to know each
other but even if you go on like one or
two days a week like three months it's a
lot of time right that's true that's
true but i do think that people the
older they get kind of move quicker
depending on what they want yeah yeah
because they get a lot less time for the
[ __ ] oh yeah i was just about to say
they're more susceptible to telling the
truth like if i'm 40 if i'm when i'm
ready to get a relationship i know
exactly what i want to do
yeah all right i'm wasting no time so
don't you think that comes down to most
people don't know themselves
it could be that it's a good point it
comes with age yeah yeah i won't lie
yeah like i said being in a relationship
for 10 years
absolutely
experiences i think i feel like i feel
like it's more so experiences yeah
because that can mature you and your
experiences can mature you right that's
you know i mean age as well
sorry going girl no i think um
i wish i think that like girls dating
with more of an age gap kind of helps
them because the guys are a little bit
ready to like commit faster you know i
agree but it's not really like pushed at
all like i never even thought about
dating older guys until i like found the
red pill to be honest
yeah because they're kind of
aren't women attracted to older guys
generally though
i wasn't like
not really like
i it was kind of weird like before 24
i could not even see a guy over 30 i was
like they're like invisible but then
when you hit like 24 25 then old guy
you're like
our dad's hot now
i was like when did that happen
for me anyway but before that no i
didn't even but the thing is with a guy
who's older he has the option though he
has an option to date a woman his age
yes
and also a younger one yeah
i mean i think women once they hit like
35 40
guys at 35 40 are looking to look
further down they're looking like 20s
guys that yeah yeah it's very if they
can
so i think like when a woman hits like
35 or 40 and stuff she needs to go look
for like i don't know 50 year old you
know guy or something i don't know you
know she starts messing around with
younger guys
and that's what the and and she's
literally those guys little like peace
yeah you know what i mean like you know
what's interesting how they have you
seen the delusion calculator for women
i've heard of it i haven't seen it no
is that when they put in all of yeah
yeah requirements and it tells you what
percentage of guys are actually like
there yeah it's interesting because i
did that for men i found the male
equivalent but i did it with like girls
in their 20s because i was like what
percentage of girls are actually in
their 20s
oh yeah
what percent do you think of girls in
western
oh i think i don't know i'm guessing it
was the us i think but i actually don't
know what percentage of women are in
their 20s yeah i'm gonna say 15
it can't be that high if you if you
think people live until 80. um
i would say like 20 20 maybe yeah what
is it what do you think i feel like 30
40. what do you think 40 percent of the
population that girls in their time no
no no no no no off the population yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah around 15 to 20
what is it i i i think it was 13
actually 13 to 18 around there so you're
kind of right that makes sense it was
um but then i was thinking about it you
can make it you can make any stat small
because if you add like then half of
girls in the us are overweight oh
yeah
that's so true yeah and then you add if
you i don't know like you don't want a
feminist it's like smaller than yeah
yeah but the thing is that i've seen the
delusion calculator on the women's side
and a lot of the time it comes out like
that man doesn't even exist oh yeah for
sure
i mean like is that everybody who are
you asking for
this man
that's what i'm trying to say you're
asking for god or something like this
man doesn't exist well and the crazy
thing is because i grew up i'm like my
dad is the like
i don't know the high value guy that the
girls were like income wise right like
he's in the top like half a percent of
earners in the u.s
so i'm like y'all ladies could not
handle one of them because one
you think he's going to pay attention to
you he works 80 hours a week
good luck like i'm like you always come
second my dad went to india for like a
month at a time to develop software
there and like start a business in india
and it was like so i'll hear these girls
like talk about what they want i'm like
do you not think you're gonna work yeah
like yeah do you not think you're gonna
do anything you think you're just gonna
say well then a lot of um what this is
being said like in the red bull
community like
uh
quote unquote average women
are not looking for quote-unquote
average men okay no they're looking for
men above average oh yeah and so if
you're looking for a man above average
that above average man isn't necessarily
looking for your average ass what's
above average
i'm just like whatever
because it's just whatever you're using
whether it be looks yeah yeah yeah yeah
every like if you're average it's a
combo yeah i'm saying if you're average
why are you not looking at your
your like thing is though i would i
would argue that
um
it's actually
women or females in general of a species
looking for the top dog is very normal
hypergamy is normal like if you look at
if you look at primates or the lion
kingdom they it's not nine lionesses to
nine male lions they choose the top male
lion
and they all choose to mate with him
primates and alpha gorillas that's the
exact same thing so whoever the top one
is
the females instinctually are more
likely to choose i think the difference
is we we are more ex we're exposed to
way more people now but i don't think
they understand what it means to be with
that man
not today i mean i agree yeah they don't
understand what it means they think that
man is going to be the same prince
charming that they've created in their
head and is that no no he's going to
you're not even going to see that dude
and
he's going to expect you to work
you might have expected my she had seven
kids for him
and then she helped him build his
business and she quit teaching to do
what he wanted to do and lived where he
wanted to live it wasn't
like i think the women of this age
of this era
want that guy like your father exactly
but they want to be like some prissy
little
i don't know internet model or something
it's like yeah that guy's not going to
want you parading yourself all over it
all over instagram my mom was on
facebook
yeah she had a really lit facebook
account we would always i would from a
young age on the facebook yeah
but it's also like it's also when you
talk about people who um who are like in
the top percentile of earners
everybody thinks that they're just
sitting at their desk with their feet up
just watching the millions roll in and
that's not yet
they're working 18 hours a week
six seven days a week 52 weeks yeah well
there's a cost to everything and people
think you can have the benefit without
the cost and that that's the problem
like
i
i didn't really know my dad that well
until i was older
like me i'm like so close with him now
and but you know that was the cost was
he was gone a lot yeah and then when i
got older and you know now i can hang
out with him all i want because he's
retired
but there's a cost to everything yeah
100 like and this and even a like even a
man like what i feel is that a man can
if we go out and find if we go to the
shop
we go to tesco or i don't know and
there's a girl on a checkout yeah and
she looks
cool all right she's nice we'll go out
on a date with her yeah it doesn't
matter if you're a multi-millionaire or
an average guy well because men men
value different things yes yeah like you
guys if she's hot enough yeah
but you're not getting the right quality
you're not gonna go to a up to a 300
pound girl and ask her out but a girl
mind if he has enough money